michelle nate congratulations you know i
gotta ask about the ring can i just see
it
you did good that's a gorgeous
so this is so fun you're so in love you
finally get to share your love with the
world how are you feeling because you
know it must be tricky when you have to
hide that from people for months
yeah we are
we are ready we are on a high we are
excited
we are exhausted we needed that but we
every everything it's been a wave of
emotions but it's it's been really nice
to just think about this moment where we
can actually
like go out in public we haven't
actually been out in public together yet
so we like keep talking about it like
we're still daydreaming a little bit but
we'll get there you know sometime today
maybe
oh i love that but yeah it's been it's
been really good yeah no literally i'm
like really looking forward to like the
little moments like we're going to be in
the airport later today uh which i
probably shouldn't have said that
don't worry i'm telling everyone in
canada all right we're gonna be in the
airport later today it's like we've been
looking forward to like little things
like that just you know
traveling together so
you know what was so special was after
the final rose so many things about that
that live show was very special but
seeing your parents together how nice is
that how well do they get along
so well very well too well i'm just
kidding but they
they i mean it's just that's kind of
what i've always wanted is just to be
able to bring two families together
you know for the holidays
we'll be spending some time in minnesota
spending some time in canada you know
the next year be able to get everybody
in the same room for the holidays
and it's just really nice to have
support from both sides and to have both
sides really truly want to genuinely get
to know the other family and i think
that's what makes this even more special
than it already is yeah and something
that's so special and after the final
you guys got a surprise 200 000
check for a down payment on your home
michelle i couldn't stop staring at your
face you were you were shocked i have
never it's it's it's kind of hard just
like surprise me at times i feel like i
catch on and i had no idea whatsoever
and that was i mean the audience was
definitely taking it in real time with
me because as you can see in my face
i had no idea that was coming i had no
idea yeah no still still like still not
like sunk in or sinking whatever the
word is still it's still just like wow
this is crazy and that's never happened
before right like i watched the bachelor
in the bachelorette all the time i don't
ever remember that happening before no
no we are incredibly grateful um i mean
this bachelor family has been very
wonderful to us they've been so
supportive
and you know
they started off as producers and all
these different things but really have
become like this
you know family and this these friends
that are going to be a part of our life
and all these big moments
housewarming parties wedding whatever it
is in the future they'll definitely be a
part of it as well so i know this is all
like so new for for us but are you
planning the wedding already or are you
just taking everything in like what's
what's on like the to-do list is it nate
you moving to minnesota first then what
like what's going on yeah we got
christmas we got new year's then we got
me moving to minnesota yeah um and then
you know we're we're definitely set on a
nice
sunny summer wedding in the uh in the
near future so
that's cool so i heard you say you're
gonna bring up to canada what are you
excited to bring her to canada oh yeah
yeah i am it's actually my first time
going to canada so
yeah i know it's going to be cold and we
thought minnesota was cold
winnipeg is a whole other story all
right
it's even different than toronto it's
cold
is crazy yeah exactly exactly that's so
exciting you know it was really fun for
us getting to watch this journey
michelle was there a moment i'm sure
there were a few but is there one moment
that really stood out for you that you
knew nate was your guy
i really you know had always have always
talked to nate about just how i wanted
like i pushed myself to be open to make
sure that i was
thinking through everything taking my
time in a situation where
you don't have a lot of time and so he
was definitely that consistent thought
in my mind the consistent thought in my
heart
um that connection was very very strong
from right off the bat and it just never
really slowed down
and so um would i be surprised if he was
the one at the end
i think everyone you know during filming
saw the way that i looked at him right
but i also had other strong
relationships as well and so i think it
was for me it was just really
nice being able to wake up that morning
of and have this clarity of like okay
this is the person that hasn't left my
mind this is the person that i can't
live without um and
yeah it's it's the person that i want to
spend the rest of my life with and it's
been really nice i mean have not looked
back since and it's it's been awesome i
love it just seeing you guys together
like you just you feel it you can't
that's just so i love it um you know
nate you recently posted on social media
you know about your journey with
michelle and and you know what she means
to you but you also said some people see
you as a walking uh warning sign or you
know maybe the way that the show is
edited people didn't get to see you know
the real truth behind the way that your
relationship developed so what do you
wish that bachelor nation got to see
um you know just just uh just some of
our moments you know what i mean like
and and i totally get it right because
it's you only gotta you only get to put
like you know a full
week's worth of of of filming into like
an hour and 15 minutes not including the
uh the commercials obviously right so
it's just like i get it it's not the
native michelle show it's the
bachelorette right so i understand that
there's there's multiple stories i need
to be told and you know um you know but
but you know selfishly of course i would
i would have liked you know all of our
our amazing moments um to be broadcasted
for the world to really see because like
it was a magical story right so um but
hey you know what we got the rest of our
lives today i was gonna say you're here
exactly this is the most important thing
exactly exactly so it is what it is and
as for the the walking red flag i mean
everybody's gonna have their their
opinion right everybody's gonna have
their opinion and um uh you know i think
i think some people are just a bit too
too quick to judge a book by its cover
you know what i mean so he could be my
walking red flag yeah
[Laughter]
yeah you will i love that
michelle how special was it for you to
have caitlyn and keisha on this journey
with you
they were so helpful just to have two
other women who had been through the
process you go through this with you
know coming into it and wanting to you
know wanting advice and hoping that you
can get advice that's going to be
helpful but really what helped is just
having these two women who have been
through the situation before have
experienced the weird feelings of dating
multiple people at once and all these
different weird events and emotions that
come with being the lead in a show like
this and so they validated my feelings
when i was you know struggling
with having strong feelings for more
than one person and what to do with that
and how to speak about that and how to
share it and is it okay and they just
they truly helped guide me through those
moments and have been supporters and
even when i you know after nate and i
were engaged and
and were off the show they just have
supported me then through re-watching it
and those emotions that you experience
and you know katelyn's offered you know
jason for help and and all these
different things and so it's just been
like this network of people that have
kind of rallied around us when whenever
we need them and it's been it's been
awesome yeah that's so special because
you know only you guys know what all
this is about we get to watch from home
we think we know what's going on but
there's a whole other experience when
you're actually doing a show like this
how would you describe your journey in
three words
let's see three words
exciting passionate passionate oh
um
wait what's the word with resilient
promise oh okay
yeah okay wait we'll do four words
that's okay
we you saw us we were like really
struggling which word to kick out no i
like that exciting
honest
passionate resilient
guys i like that that's that's good
those are some good uh descriptive words
they're very important elements to have
in a relationship and just to wrap
things up um obviously when asked about
clayton we know he's the new bachelor
what are your thoughts on this casting
i mean clayton was not necessarily
somebody who the audience got to see and
get to go like get to know but i
clean was like the what is it when you
like take out of the gates and you're
you know it takes you a minute to speed
up but then you get your momentum and
that was definitely clayton and you know
unfortunately our connection wasn't the
connection for me and so as he's
starting to pick up emotion or momentum
and show his personality you know he was
let go but it put him in this position
where he's now having the opportunity to
hopefully find his person which is
something that he
genuinely wants to do yeah and so he
he's a good guy he has a good head on
his shoulders he's
funny he can rap he you know
he has some hidden surprises that a lot
of people have not seen yet and i i hope
that they get to see that yeah um in
this season
um i'm just looking at your body
language i just love seeing you guys
together you're so freaking cute
congratulations on everything and yeah
it's so exciting all the uh new things
are gonna happen between you guys it's
really cool hey thanks so much thank you
thanks guys